je vais à la recherche en fait deux
films qui me qui m'interpelle et qui me
stimule tout simplement ce que je ne
faisais pas forcément au début les
débuts de gaspard ulliel c'était il ya
quinze ans il était beau en faire tomber
emmanuelle béart chez téchiné depuis
gaspar a grandi je suis 34 ans il est
toujours beau il a brouillé les pistes
entre acteur et mannequin
il est acteur ou menger bon un fardeau
qu'il porte bien c'est pas juste une
belle plante il se passe beaucoup de
choses sur son visage du mr et de la
sensualité une beauté étrange qui a
attiré guillaume nicloux le réalisateur
de vale of love il plonge gaspard ulliel
en pleine jungle dans les confins du
monde tu verras un mobile pour lons et
roberta ce n est que je ne lâcherai pas
indochine 1945 la guerre racontée comme
une névrose sexuelle tiens ça rime avec
miel c'est l'option de puissance
sexuelle qui est à la fois dominatrice
inquiétante et en même temps une perse
désirable il a fait l'unanimité en saint
laurent dans l'anti biopic de bertrand
bonello le rôle d'une vie avant son
césar pour juste la fin du monde de
xavier dolan souvent mutique repérable à
sa fossette
il est le visage énigmatique du cinéma
français sur lequel ce projet tous nos
fantasmes
oui oui tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme tu es de pulse un expat béninois
ne comptait plus sur lui pour être la
personne que vous attendez de lui une
icône papier glacé un beau gosse dans
des grosses productions non merci au mur
island match physique je préférais
m'orienter vers des films qui me touche
vraiment de façon évidente et est réel
c'est aussi lié à mon rôle d'égérie chez
chanel qui me donne quand même une forme
d'autonomie financière qui me permet
justement depuis plusieurs années
d'attendre aussi les projets qui nous
plaisent réellement une égérie bleus
comme ses yeux dans une publicité
célèbre parfum de cinéma puisque
réalisée par scorsese
voilà gaspard ulliel paradoxalement
libre de choisir ses films
car liée à une grande marque de luxe qui
s'est pas compromis là dedans parce
qu'il n'a pas été vendre 35 parfum 14
sacs à main il a fait une petite
campagne on change pour avec kate moss
une fois will a été mannequin mais juste
subtilement dosé il a réussi à sortir à
mon avis de son physique pour imposer
des choses on est plus cruelle plus plus
plus compliqué je pense que tous ces
rôles tourne autour de cette question là
de son physique et d'une entité d'entre
ce qu'il est à l'intérieur et son
physique ou son physique provoque
meilleur exemple saint laurent en 2014
il se glisse dans la peau du grand
couturier français y est celle la
quintessence du style incarné par ulliel
haute couture c'est vraiment un film
pensé autour de gaspard ulliel et puis
il incarne vraiment saint laurent non
pas dans une sorte de mimétisme un peu
lourdingue de jeu représente saint
laurent comme on l'a connu mais chacun
de l'esprit saint laurent c'est un grand
film de vampires le film de bertrand
bonello pas mieux gaspard ulliel pour
jouer les vampires
le vampire ulliel joue un saint laurent
au charme vénéneux il envoûte cannes et
embrasse le monde désire et aussi à
l'international et ne nous sommes avec
the works of life staff bête avec death
cab for doha autour de lui de ce corps
de ce qu'il incarne à l'écran et en même
temps il ya une part ténébreuse en lui
qu'on voit vraiment holcim de bonello la
première réplique du film de modèle aux
c je voudrais dormir ça je viens pour
dormir et un truc comme ça chez gaspard
ulliel d'un peu fantomatique un peu
inquiétant pas étonnant qu'il ait joué
hannibal lecter en fait c'est à dire que
ça lui va très très bien de jouer à la
fois les anges et les démons hannibal ou
l'incursion mitigé de gaspard ulliel à
hollywood
en 2007 le film sur la jeunesse
d'hannibal lecter est un échec
commercial
mais ces deux dents guillaume nicloux a
repéré son soldat rongé par la vengeance
pour les concerts du monde
j'ai été frappé j'ai été frappé par un
physique particulier je crois c'est son
visage d'abord son usage ce regard ce
sourire
ensuite la façon dont petits bouts ge
gaspard représentait
la chair et le sang qu'il était
nécessaire aux personnages pour exister
ouais c'est pas forcément le film dont
je suis le plus fier jal avait marqué
j'arrive à être suffisamment crédibles
dans un exercice aussi incertain et
période celui ci c'est vrai que deux
voilà de reprendre ce rôle c'était quand
même assez fou une expérience périlleuse
le jeune gagny balla autant senti
l'odeur du sang que la pression des
studios américains
ça s'apparente est un film de studio
avec quand même un contrôle assez
verrouillé de la part des producteurs
avec un producteur présent sur le
plateau en permanence qui vient dictée
c'est une autre façon de concevoir les
choses on peut pas modifier une ligne de
dialogue sinon il faut passer par
l'agent de l'auteur qui c'est mais c'est
intéressant et puis surtout j'ai
découvert tout tous tous l'envers en
fait de ce genre de production ou
derrière il ya un il faut assurer un
travail de promotion qui est colossal
on le soupçonne d'avoir préféré tourner
chez xavier dolan juste la fin du monde
adapté de la pièce de lagarce ulliel
joue le bouleversant louis cet homme qui
revient chez lui pour annoncer qu'il va
mourir un rôle de t&e confronté à une
famille asphyxiante
chanter mais comment commence à chanter
mais se connaissent pas ils se
connaissent pas maman pourquoi tu cries
tefal ou quoi jamais jamais il son nom
était pas là j'avais oublié j'avais pas
réalisé on n'a pas vraiment envie d'une
drôle de manière
c'était lui le personnage principal de
ce film où finalement il était quand
même entourée d'énormes acteurs et
pointures du cinéma avec acea lui
côtière qui prennent de la place en
général à l'écran est en fait pourtant
vous voyez que gaspard quoi il était là
et il disait pas grand chose mais tous
passé un regard presque à un soupir
juste fermer les paupières
[Musique]
dans juste la fin du monde en fait
gaspard ulliel et une sorte de miroir du
spectateur et c'est sur son regard qu'on
voit toute la violence de cette famille
il faut un acteur qui serait un forain
physique qu'on connaît un physique on a
envie de suivre et en même temps qu on l
instant que le masque soit en train de
se révéler en permanence et ça chez
gaspard ulliel que ce soit dans les
confins du monde dans saint laurent ou
non jusqu'à fin du monde on a ça à
chaque fois ils jouent les espèces de
statuts qui sont en train de se casser
la gueule
le film lui vaut le césar du meilleur
acteur il n'est pas là pour venir le
chercher mais fait lire à xavier dolan
une lettre dans laquelle s'exprime son
goût des mots certains ne manqueront pas
de relever la malaise d'être récompensé
avec un film au titre d' apocalypse
il paraît que les belles histoires de
cinéma sont celles qui au début ne
laisse pas présager de la fin n'est ce
pas la raison d'être de cette vie sur
grand écran
que vous soyez acteur ou spectateur la
fin d'un film ne sera jamais la fin d'un
monde
mais la première aventure à venir
l'esthète ulliel courtois et raffiné
n'en finit pas de troubler les metteurs
en scène un peu plus tôt cette année
dont eva avec isabelle huppert benoît
jacquot a fait de lui un dramaturge
gigolo talentueux et escrocs au charme
insondable ça m'embête un peu de dire ça
mais mais je suis obligé d'être de le
reconnaître c'est que les rôles pour
l'instant où j'ai été le meilleur c'est
peut-être ce qui rejoignent une part de
moi-même est ce que je peux en fait
renvoyer comme ça d' assez introverti
avec une propension à laisser aller en
forme des deux mondes intérieurs
oui
travaux comme d'hab quoi j'ai
l'impression que gaspard ulliel et aussi
condamné à jouer l'ambiguïté sexuelle
est quelque chose de félins chez lui et
en même temps de très féminin de très
masculin je pense que c'est ça qui crée
quelque chose d'inquiétant à l'écran
gaspard ulliel à mon avis est une icône
queer malgré lui en fait c'est à dire
que je pense pas qu'ils construisent ça
et qui provoque ça à l'écran et bonello
et dolan et guillaume nicloux en font
une sorte de d'héroïne courir en fait le
garçon la fossette n'a pas fini de
fasciner
[Musique]